previously on the walking hot no buts
no buts that was cropping everything
beyond that barricade whoa that is the
closing Club a poor shocked man by
accident
whoops I have to get back climate sorry
for scourge I just want to get back to
my people back to Clementine
all right I'm clear it so Mead you've
gotten worse
who's this oh we have a soccer it's a
dark mean he changed the saver help us
please I'll see what I can do
it's gonna be a zombie oh thank god
[Music]
what are you doing that's right all
right Wow the GAO Emre my name is
brunoise welcome back to another
exciting episode
house on the whole meets doing okay as
well as can be expected under the
circumstances I did what I could for him
cleaned out the wound but he's got a
real infection running a fever without
antibiotics I will you quit pacing
you're making everyone nervous why are
you even still here yeah hey if your
friend really can get that boat working
you're taking me with you as payment for
saving your asses I figure that's fair
enough don't you Smalley's going with us
huh we'll kind of like oh I want Ben to
die no and good news or the bad news
I want the bad news that's good they're
bad news out of the way first bad news
is she's not taking us anywhere the
shape she's in right now gas tanks empty
and the battery's dead
so what's the good news that's it that's
all she needs some gas ha ha other than
that she's good to go well how are we
supposed to get that stuff
my bike Rafa sounds like Crawford is the
one place that has everything we need
maybe we should try there
now hold on ah certainly we have to try
if there are people left in this city
who are still alive who still have
supplies what harm can it do to ask
trust me you don't know these people I
do you showing up with a wounded man
might as well put a noose around his
neck they don't exactly welcome children
with open arms either what the hell kind
of a place are we talking about here the
worst kind but I don't see what other
choice we have and just how exactly do
you figure we do this because from what
I've heard that place ain't exactly
friendly to outsiders sneaking has got
to be some way we can sneak in there
undetected there might actually be a way
I know the sewer system that runs
beneath Crawford like the back of my
hand y'all wouldn't happen to have a map
by any chance where did I say
I think I could lead us through so we
could pass under the perimeter and right
into the center where they keep their
supplies we come up right underneath
them take them by surprise
grab what we need and get out before
they even knew what hit him
that's actually not the worst idea I've
ever heard I mean it's close but I don't
know maybe it could work I've thought
about it before just never had the
people to do it but I think if we all
work together we could all right that's
third that what do you want return for
all this help you're giving us Crawford
doesn't just have what you need for your
boat they're all so well stocked with
medical stuff ramen medicine that my
people could use just as yours could we
can do this we have to so it's decided
then
do it we're going to Crawford we can do
this I know it
hell yeah we can are we seriously
talking about this I mean what about the
risk no been justified I'd rather take a
chance on doing something than just
sitting around here waiting to die that
boat out there is an answered prayer
just gotta push a little bit farther are
you in or out
we should go tonight under cover of dark
I'll go let my people know give you all
a chance to prepare I'll be back before
midnight be careful that's how I'm still
alive I breath I told you to stay in
your room how long have you been there
is it going to be dangerous
it's what gonna be dangerous don't worry
climbing Crawford
I don't know I can't lie to get clear
mind just don't know
I don't want anyone else to die
neither died at the water club you know
times we have to take that kind of risk
I guess I should go get ready
oh say what now you said you'd meet all
of us to do this and you said I'm a big
help remember I don't know Molly said
Crawford is the only place left in
Savannah that still has people that
means it must be where my mom and dad
are all right yeah I guess but I mean
it's dangerous for children
we're not going it's just too dangerous
for children especially you said I'm
supposed to always stay close to you
can't I come with you
do I get to decide okay but do you have
to promise to stay quiet and do exactly
what you're told the whole time were
there
okay I'm gonna go get ready we have a
boat but we don't have battery or
medical supplies or gas so we got to
break into the Evo guys steal their [ __ ]
maybe hump a few people and a lab it
check out what I found in the garage
hatchet hacksaw some other tools might
come in handy on this little break-in
boys can I talk to you a minute
Shane what's up I took another look at
the boat
she's a 30-footer I mean we can all a
Fed so we're gonna have a capacity
problem boat that size ain't gonna hold
more than five people even with one of
them a kid Christa assuming everyone
makes it back alive it's still one too
many even if we cut Molly loose before
this is over you're gonna have to make a
decision
oh [ __ ] serious look I'm just saying if
we want the best chance of
what are you doing this that's the
dachshund Brie she can help us with what
help us how I was a student at the
school where Crawford keeps their
supplies I know the layout with her help
we're in and out faster anyone have a
problem with that
I guess well then what are we waiting
for let's get moving
hold up just a sec you ready ready
whoa hold on a minute you're not taking
her with us did you not hear anything I
said about the kind of place Crawford is
if you take her in there and they find
her
this little girls not just excess
baggage she's gotten us out of a tight
spot more than once she's coming deal
with it you heard the man let's move out
I really don't know about this idea
brothers I hope I didn't make the wrong
to say then [ __ ] off
it's my hatchet I really hope then steps
up and do something for the group this
time since so long and he just [ __ ] up
beer boxes on the center of Crawford the
old school should be directly above us
okay people this is it remember the plan
kill all sons of [ __ ] stay hidden and
we stay together we find what do we need
and we get the hell out before anyone
even knows we're there got it and that
part about staying close and it goes
double for you
someone's gonna die someone's gonna die
and then we're gonna have to choose
between one of them I think what's up
with this Crawford place anyway thanks
girl I really don't like this I think
they know we're coming disappointed it's
just strange I think they are waiting
for us okay we're gonna kill you wait
for our signal then follow us over got
it okay kitty let's do this quiet no
shooting unless there's no other choice
right behind you what am I gonna do here
am I gonna kill them I don't know what I
feel about killing another bird I gotta
smack his head up higher then kinda
inspect the skull what the [ __ ] well
[Music]
it's Crawford [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is a walker to an inside
here
they're inside that
well I'm glad we got Clem in with us
oh stop with the jump yet Jesus Christ
game [ __ ] [ __ ]
do you think they saw us I think yes I
don't know your guess is as good as mine
crime are you alright
what the hell happened here I thought
this place was supposed to be secure
what always happens I guess in the end
the dead always win oh man you're so
screwed no this is good
Wow house is good what the [ __ ] is this
good before everyone at Crawford was
smart and they had guns
now that dumb they don't hey trying to
look on the bright side yeah I thought
thought too actually I agree so long as
we don't let him box us in we can still
do this the plan hasn't changed the plan
hasn't changed
everytime Walker's show up the plan
changes do you even have any idea how
many of them are out there
no you want to do a head count or do you
want to get what we need and get the
hell out of here I want to plan B you
wanted too bad I think I know which way
to head I don't really trust her so I
mean she wanted to kill us I got a bad
feeling about this
well then you are a [ __ ] - shut
up
I think we're walking in a trap here
she's walking moving here well we're
pretty [ __ ] do it's gonna be empty we
all know that looks okay everybody in I
don't know about this rest I don't know
about this
what is this music
I don't trust her standing there Wow
figures we're just kind of open it can't
be that difficult it's not a mat looks
like they were using this room as some
kind of command center but are they
really [ __ ] I understood now what
where do we start looking does it make
sense if they were like the ultimate
survival room here what
[Music]
just give me a sec
what battery any idea where we could
find our battery maybe at the auto shop
there used to be one in the alley
outside the fire escape yep it's called
Herrmann's you can't miss it
well fewer can we find some fuel for the
boat there's a maintenance shed across
from the playground here if they were
storing fuel that's probably where it'll
be we have the medicine right here
nurse's station they were using it as a
medical facility how do you know that
yeah
just makes sense doesn't it you've been
in crossfire oh can we trust them all
the moon to the maintenance shed for the
fuel can't we trust Molly mo I don't
know about Molly I'll come too no two
peoples enough Ben just stay here see if
you can use any of those tools we
brought to get that armory door open
they might need to shoot our way out of
here I'll go for the medicine I'll come
with you I know what to take okay guess
that leaves me to go find us a battery
I'll go with you watch your back okay
we've got a plan
everyone be careful stay close to one
another we'll all meet back here good
luck
later Molly yeah we can trust Molly she
saved us what about me what can I do I
need you to stay here with Ben and watch
over our command center I'm putting you
in charge of it okay I can't put Ben in
charge you're leaving me with Ben
yeah ieaving you with Ben I'm leaving
him with you understand okay
hahahahahahahaha before you know
a rug a shelf school mat let's check the
mat actually so according to Bree
fuelers at the maintenance shed medicine
might be at the nurse's office and a
battery would probably be in the auto
shop out through here
so we go out we follow the corridor and
then we enter all right seems simple
enough so we're here
the alleyway to the auto shops down here
known or not i guess i followmolly you
should go there
wow she's fast
this must be the door to the alleyway
with the auto shop is yeah it's said
that with a little smiling I don't trust
this Bobby you up here Molly a she's
gonna do something I'm not going that
way Molly delivers will be shot on sight
that's nice
I don't like this one bit
don't shoot me a TV it's a hole in the
ceiling that was easy enough now what's
your plan on going back there stupid
I need something to hold it open it's
jammed tight I don't like this breath I
feel it really like someone is watching
me don't get too close all right
bow what are you doing with tires have
hats where was this guy diving leave him
he's mine
I think nice to see you oh he knows who
it is what call them that down what's
wrong with you what's the matter
never seen someone kill a geek before
not like that he's wearing medical
scrubs some kind of scientist or doctor
maybe yeah well [ __ ] no did you find us
away in yeah but the garage doors jammed
can't raise it wide it I'm so confused
wasn't what she the one following a hot
a problem look what I found
uh hello oh yeah that'll work
see that's what you get bounce borrow
come on male that fence is not gonna
hold itself seriously we could easily
take out three zombies Oh edge three of
them come on
they're so slow anyway oh [ __ ] alright
fine
Larry today
oh he's still alive for zombies I think
Molly will die I don't know
all right here's the batteries and [ __ ]
look around I'll make sure no stragglers
get under the store I can't reach it up
there well no [ __ ] Sherlock
no power come on looks like it's the
hose for the lift hydraulics
well then hose down don't think I can
pry that holds apart with just my hands
maybe there Jackie cut it with alright
let's find something to cut it with
all right well I can see where their
batteries should be god damnit perfect
well I don't think the other one will
have one then what's up my lemur
something you need now Mario that hook
thing of yours I don't know
Hilda and I have been through a lot hell
no burr that's what I call her don't
judge please can I borrow Hilda I'll
take good care of her she won't get a
scratch
I got your promise now not a scratch
jeez women and their lesbian
relationships I'll never understand all
right
yeah dress did good no [ __ ]
I'll try to hold them off hurry there's
the back finally something goes right
all right you just got a snap a step up
and snippets tapas tapas I bet and I
would have it I put it in here I'll
carry it
okay follow me she's gonna steal the
battery move your ass
mob your [ __ ] ass that I am a
damn Bay Amazon beer holy [ __ ] they're
fat
right now silent
wow she's good
she's really good ah
we're on the roof you ever stop
complaining come on I didn't still not
sure if I trust Molly and Hilda but I
think I can trust them she's really
badass though I hope she's on our side
come on what are you chicken jump I am
the ticket yeah calling me a cheque gun
I still don't trust anything what's
going on here I don't like that but
later something I gotta do first what
give me the battery later wait you've
still got the battery yeah I think I'll
hold on to it make sure you don't leave
without me
that's probably a good idea if I were
her Bali damn it what the hell is she
doing all right Bryce I'm gonna have to
end it here like a prepare to be enjoyed
subscribe come with me and I see an X
I'm sorry alright
you